The COVID-19 pandemic is hitting the global entertainment industry hard.
But Big Hit's financial performance continues to shine.
In the first half of this year, it reported 49.7 billion won,...
...about 43 million US dollars in profits...
...as its online concerts and merchandise sales...
...more than offset event cancellations during the COVID-19 pandemic.
And last year alone, the company posted 587 billion won in revenue.
About 500 million US dollars, double of that from the year earlier.
The hype around K-pop and BTS' global fame in particular...
...has benefited South Korea's entertainment industry.
Now, Big Hit is hoping the K-pop stardust will also help it win over the capital markets.